the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
alright so the past few weeks we've been
looking at double integrals in the plane
line integrals in the plane and what we
are going to do now from now on
basically until the end of the term will
be very similar stuff with in space so
we're going to learn how to do triple
integrals in space flux in space work in
space divergence curl all that so that
means basically you know if you were
very on top of what we've been doing
this past few weeks then it will be just
the same with one more coordinate and
you'll see there are some differences
but conceptually it's quite a similar
there are a few tricky things for now
that also means that you know with the
stuff that you're not sure about in the
plane then I encourage you to you know
review the material that we've done over
the last few weeks to make sure that
everything in the plane is completely
clear to you because it will be much
harder to understand stuff in space if
things are still shaky in the plane okay
so anyway the plan is we are going to
basically go for the same stuff but in
space so it shouldn't be surprising that
we'll start today with triple integrals
okay so the way triple integrals work is
if I give you a function of three
variables X Y Z and I give you some
region in space so some solid then I can
take the integral over this region of
our function f DV where DV stands for
the volume element okay so what it means
is we'll just take you know every single
little piece of our solid take the value
the value of F air multiplied by the
small volume of each little piece and
sum all these things together and so
this volume element here well for
example if you are doing the integral in
rectangular coordinates that will become
DX dy DZ or any permutation of that
because of course we have lots of
possible orders of integration to choose
from so
rather than bore you with you know
fairway and all sorts of things let's
just do examples and you'll see
basically if you understand how to set
up I tell it in integrals in two
variables then you basically understand
how to do them in three variables you
just have to be a bit more careful and
there's one more step okay so let's take
our first triple integral to be on the
region so of course there's two
different things as always there's the
region of integration and there's a
function we're integrating now the
function we're integrating well it will
come in handy when you actually try to
evaluate the integral but as you can see
probably the new part is really hard to
set it up so the function won't really
matter that much for me so in the
examples I'll do today the functions
will be kind of silly so for example
let's say that we want to look at the
region between two paraboloids one given
by Z equals x squared plus y squared the
other is Z equals four minus x squared
minus y squared and so I haven't given
you yet function to integrate okay this
is not the function to integrate this is
what describes the region where I will
integrate my function and let's say that
I just want to find the volume of this
region which is the triple integral of
just one DV okay similarly remember when
we try to find the area of a region in
the plane we were just integrating one
da here we integrate one DVD that will
give us the volume now I know that you
can imagine how to actually do this one
as a double integral but you know the
goal of a game is to set up the triple
integral it's not to actually find the
volume so what does that look like
well Z equals X square plus y squared
that's one of our favorite paraboloids
that's something that looks like a
parabola with its bottom at the origin
that you spin about the z axis and Z
equals 4 minus X square minus y squared
well that's also a paraboloid but this
one is pointing down and when you take x
equals y equals 0 you get Z equals 4 so
it starts at 4 and it goes down like
that okay so the solid that we'd like to
consider is what's in between in here so
it has a curve atop which is this
downward paraboloid a curvy button which
is the over paraboloid and what about
the sides where do you have any idea
what we get here yeah it's going to be a
circle because the entire picture is
invariant by rotation on the x axis the
z axis so you know if you look at the
picture just say in the Y Z plane you
get this point on that point and when
you rotate when you rotate everything
around the z axis you will just get a
circle here ok so our goal is to find
the volume of this thing and there are
lots of things I could do to simplify
the calculation or even not do it as a
triple integral at all but I want to
actually set it up as a triple integral
just to show how we do that ok so the
first thing we need to do is choose an
order of integration and here well I
don't know if you can see it yet but
hopefully soon that will be intuitive to
you I claim that I would like to start
by integrating first over Z what's the
reason for that well the reason is if I
give you x and y then you can find
quickly what's the bottom and top values
of Z for that choice of x and y is if I
have x and y given then I can find above
that
what is the bottom Z and the top Z
corresponding to you know the vertical 9
above that point the portion of it
that's inside our solid so somehow the
bottom Z and a top Z and so the top Z is
actually on the downward paraboloid so
it's 4 minus X square minus y squared
the bottom value of Z is X square plus y
squared okay so if I want to start to
set this up I will write triple integral
and then so let's say I'm going to do it
DZ first and then say dy DX doesn't
really matter so then for a given value
of x and y I claim Z goes from the
bottom surface the bottom phase is Z
equals x squared plus y squared the top
phase is 4 minus x squared minus y
squared okay is that ok with everyone
yeah any questions so far yes
why did I start with Z that's a very
good question so I could choose whatever
order I want but let's say I did X first
then to find the inner integral bounds I
would need to say okay I've chosen
values of C in the inner integral you've
fixed the two other variables and you're
just going to value that one and you
need to find bounds for it so if I
integrate over X first I have to solve
and serve a following question say I'm
given values of y and z what are the
bounds for X so that would mean I'm
slicing my solid by lines that are
parallel to the x axis and see it's kind
of hard to find what are the values of x
at the front and at the back I mean it's
possible but it's easier to actually
first look for Z at the top and button
yes
dy DX or DX dy no it's completely at
random I mean you can see x and y place
symmetric holes so you know if you look
at it it's reasonably clear that Z
should be the easiest one to set up
first for what comes next XY or YX it's
the same yes yes it will be easier to
use in illegal coordinates I'll get to
that just as soon as I'm done with this
one okay so let's continue a bit with
that and I mean as you mentioned
actually we don't actually want to do it
with XY in the end in a few minutes
we'll actually switch to similar equal
coordinates but for now we don't even
know what they are so okay so I've done
the inner integral by looking at you
know if I slice by vertical lines what
is the top width is the bottom for a
given value of x and y so the bounds in
the inner integral depend on both the
middle and outer variables next I need
to figure out what values of x and y I
will be interested in and the answer for
that is well the values of x and y that
I want to look at all those that are in
the shade of my region so in fact to set
up
the middle and outer bounds what I want
to do is project my solid so my solid
looks like this kind of thing and I
don't render how to call it but what's
interesting now is I want to look at the
shadow that it casts in the XY plane and
of course that shadow will just be the
disc that's directly below this disc
here that's separating the two halves of
the solid and so now I will want to
integrate over so I want to look at all
the XY z-- X&Y in the shadow so now I'm
left with actually something we've
already done namely setting up a double
integral of our x and y so if it helps
here we don't strictly need it but if it
helps you know it could be useful to
actually draw a picture of the shadow in
the XY plane so here it would just look
again like a disc and set it up
now the question is how do we find the
size of this disk the size of this
shadow well basically we have to figure
out where our two power batteries
intersect there's nothing else okay so
one way to how to find the shadow in the
XY plane well here actually we know the
answer a priori but even if we didn't we
could just say well our engine lives
wherever the bottom surface is below the
top surface okay so we want to look at
things wherever the bottom value of Z is
less than the top value of Z I mean less
or less unequal that's the same thing so
the bottom value of Z is x squared plus
y squared
should be less than four minus x squared
minus y squared and if you solve for
that then you will get well so let's
move these guys over here you'll get 2x
squared plus 2y squared less than 4 that
becomes x squared plus y squared less
than 2 so that means that's a disk of
radius square root of 2 okay
so we kind of knew in advance it was
going to be a disc but what we've
learned now is that this radius is
square root of two so if we want to set
up if we really want to set it up using
dy/dx like I started then we can do it
because we know so for the middle
integral now we want to fix a value of x
and for that fixed value of x we want to
figure out the bounds for Y well the
answer is y goes from here to here
what's here well here Y is square root
of 2 minus x squared and here it's
negative square root of 2 minus x
squared so Y will go from negative
square root of 2 minus x squared to a
positive squared and then X will go from
negative 2 to the whole - if that's not
completely clear to you then I encourage
you to go over how we set up the
volunteer also again ok does that make
sense kind of yeah
well so when we set up remember we're
setting up a double integral dy DX here
so when we do it divide X it means we
slice this region of the plane by
vertical line segments in V so this
middle guy would be what used to be the
inner integral so in the inner remember
you fix the value of x and you ask
yourself what is the range of values of
Y in my region so Y goes from here to
here and what here and here R depends on
the value of X how well we have to find
the relation between x and y at this
point these points are on the circle of
radius would two so if you want this
circle maybe I should have written is x
squared plus y squared equals two and if
you solve for y given x you get plus
minus root of 2 minus x squared yes is
there a way to compute this with
symmetry well certainly yeah this solid
looks sufficiently symmetric that
actually you could certainly if you
finally if you don't want to do the
whole disk you could just do quarter
disks and multiply by 4 you could even
just look at the lower half of the solid
and multiply then you know by 2 so total
by 8 so yeah certainly there's lots of
ways to make it slightly easier by using
symmetry now the most spectacular way to
use symmetry here of course is to use
that we have this rotation symmetry and
switch actually you know not do this guy
in XY coordinates but instead in polar
coordinates so
so the smarter thing to do would be to
use polar coordinates instead of x and y
of course we want to keep the Z I mean
we're very happy with Z the way it is
but we'll just change x and y to cos
theta or sine theta because well let's
see actually how we would evaluate this
guy so well actually let's not it's kind
of boring but so if you start well let
me just point out one small thing here
sorry before I do that so if you start
computing the inner integral ok so let
me not do that yet side so if you try to
compute the inner integral
you'll be integrating from x squared
plus y squared - 4 minus x squared minus
y squared DZ well that will integrate to
Z between these two bounds so you will
get 4 minus 2x squared minus 2y squared
now when you put that into the remaining
ones you'll get something that's
probably not very pleasant of 4 minus 2x
squared minus 2y squared dy DX and here
you see that to evaluate this you would
switch to polar coordinates
oh by the way so you know if your
initial instincts had been to you know
given that we just want the volume you
could also have found the volume just by
doing a double integral of the height
between the top and bottom
well you would just have gotten this
right because this is the height between
top and bottom so it's all the same it
doesn't really matter but with this of
course we'll be able to integrate all
sorts of functions not just one order of
a solid so we'll do we'll be able to do
much more than just volumes okay so
let's see how do we do it with polar
coordinate instead well so well that
would become so let's see so I want to
keep DZ but then DX dy or dy DX would
become our dr d-theta and if i try to
set up the bounds well I probably
shouldn't keep this X square plus y
squared around but X square plus y
squared is easy in terms of R and theta
that's just R squared okay I mean in
general I could have something that
depends also on theta that's perfectly
legitimate but here it simplifies
doesn't it and this guy up here 4 minus
X square minus y squared becomes 4 minus
R squared and now the integral that we
have to do over RN theta well we look
again at the shadow the shadow is still
a disc of radius 4 - that hasn't changed
and now we know how to NT to set up this
integral in polar coordinates R goes
from 0 to 2 and theta goes from 0 to 2pi
and now it becomes actually easier to
evaluate
okay so now we have actually a name for
this because we're doing it in space so
these are called
actually cylindrical coordinates so in
fact you already knew about central
coordinates even if you did not know the
name okay so the idea of syllable
coordinates is that instead of x y&z to
locate a point in space you will use
three coordinates one of them is
basically how high it is above the XY
plane so that will be Z and then you
will use polar coordinates for the
projection of your point in the XY plane
so R will be the distance from the z
axis and theta will be the angle from
the x axis cannot o clock wise so the
one thing to be careful about is because
of a usual convention that we make the x
axis point to others theta equals zero
is no longer to the right now if it
equals zero is to the front and the
angle is measured from the font counter
clockwise okay so and of course if you
want to know how to convert between XYZ
and R theta Z well the formulas are just
the same as in usual polar coordinates R
cos theta R sine theta and Z remains Z
okay so why are these called cylindrical
coordinates by the way well let's say
that I give you the equation R equals a
where a is some constant say I pulls one
for example so I calls one into D that
used to be just a circle of radius one
now well in space a single equation
actually defines a
face not just the curve anymore and the
set of points where r is a well that's
all the points that are distance a from
the z axis so in fact what you get this
way is a cylinder of radius a centered
on the z axis okay so that's why they're
called cylindrical coordinates by the
weight so now similarly if you look at
the equation you know theta equals some
given value well so that used to be just
away from the origin now that becomes a
vertical half plane W if I set the value
of theta and let RZ very well is always
positive but basically that means I'm
taking a vertical plane that comes out
in this direction ok any questions about
cylindrical coordinates yes yes I'm
saying when you when you fix theta you
get only a half plane not a full plane I
mean it goes all the way up and down but
it doesn't go back to the other side of
the z axis why that's because R is
always positive by convention so you
know first of all here we say theta is
zero at the back we say theta is PI we
don't say theta is zero and is negative
we say R is positive and theta is PI
it's a convention largely but sticking
with this convention really will help
you to set up the integrals properly I
mean otherwise there's just too much
risk for mistakes yes
well it depends so question is if I were
to use semi try to do this one would I
multiply by four or by two well it
depends on how much symmetry you're
using you know so I mean no it's it's
your choice you can multiply by two by
four by eight depending on how much you
cut it so it depends on what simpler you
use what's going to use the century
between top and bottom you'd say well
the volume is twice the lower half if
you use the you know left and right half
you would say it's twice each half if
you do actually you cut it into four
pieces when you know and so on so it
depends on and again you don't have to
use the symmetry it's just you know if
you actually if you don't think of using
polar coordinates then it can save you
from doing you know you can just start
at zero here and here and you know
simplify things a tiny bit but okay oh
yes
so to define a vertical full plane well
first of all it depends on whether it
passes for the z-axis or not you know if
it doesn't then you'd have to remember
how you do in polar coordinates
I mean basically the answer is if you
have a vertical plane you know so it
doesn't depend on the Z the equation
does not involve is it only involves R
and theta and how it involves R and
theta is exactly the same as when you do
a line in polar coordinates in the plane
so if it's a line passing through the
origin you'd say well theta is either
some value of the other one if it's a
line that doesn't pass for the origin
when it's more tricky but hopefully
you've seen how to do that ok let's move
on a bit
so one thing to know I mean basically
the important thing to remember is that
the volume element in silikal
coordinates
well dxdydz
becomes r dr d-theta DZ and that
shouldn't be surprising because let's
just you know DX dy becomes rdrd theta
and DZ remains DZ i mean so you know the
way to think about it if you want is
that if you take a little piece of solid
in space so it has some height Delta Z
and it has a base which has some area
Delta a then the small volume Delta V is
equal to the area of the base times the
height so now when you make the things
infinitely small you will get DV is da
times DZ and you can use whichever
formula you want for our in the XY plane
okay now in practice you know you choose
which order you integrate in as you've
probably seen a favorite of mine is Z
first because very often you'll know
what the top and bottom of your solid
look like and then you will reduce to
just something in the XY plane but there
might be situations where it's actually
easier to start first with DX dy or rdrd
theta and then saved easy for lists and
if you've seen how to in single variable
calculus you know the disk and shell
methods for finding volumes that's
exactly you know the dilemma of you know
shells versus disks one of them is you
to Z first to value to Z last
okay so what are things we can do now
with triple integrals well we can find
the volume of solids by just integrating
DV and we've seen that we can find the
mass of a solid okay so if we have a
density Delta which remember Delta is
basically the mass divided by the volume
okay so the small mass element maybe I
should have written that as DM the mass
element is density times DV so now this
is the real physical density you know if
you're given a material it will be
usually the density will be in grams per
cubic meter or cubic inch or whatever I
mean there's tons of different units but
so then the mass of your solid will be
just the triple integral of density DV
because you just sum the mass of each
little piece and of course if the
density is one then it just becomes the
volume now it shouldn't be surprising to
you that we can also do classics that we
had seen by plane such as the average
value of a function the center of mass
and moment of inertia
okay so the average value of a function
f of X Y Z in the region R that would be
f bar would be one of the volume of the
region times the triple integral of f DV
or if we have a density and we want to
take a weighted average then we take one
over the mass where the mass is the
triple integral of the density times the
triple integral of f density D D so as
particular cases there's again the
notion of center of mass of a solid so
that's the point that somehow right in
the middle of the solid that's the point
mass by which you know there's a point
at which you should put a point mass so
that it would be equivalent from a point
of view of dealing with forces and
translation effects of course not for
rotation but so the center of mass of a
solid is just given by taking the
average values of x y&z okay so it's a
special case where you know X bar is 1
over the mass times triple integral of X
density DT and same thing with y&z
and of course you know very often you
can use symmetry to not have to compute
all three of them for example if you
look at this solid that we had when I
guess I've erased it now but you
remember what it looked like well it was
pretty obvious that the center of mass
would be in the z axis so no need to
waste time computing X bar and y bar and
in fact you could also find Z bar by
symmetry between the top and bottom I
let you figure that out
of course symmetry only works if you say
symmetry only works if the density is
also symmetric all right even if I had
taken my guy to be you know heavier at
the front and at the back then it would
no longer be true that X bar would be
zero okay next on the list is moment of
inertia and actually in a way moment of
inertia in 3d is easier conceptually
than in 2d so why is that well because
now the various flavors that we had come
together in a nice way so the moment of
inertia of an axis so with respect to an
axis would be again given by the triple
integral of the distance to the axis
squared times density times DV and in
particular so you know we have our solid
and we might skew it using any of the
coordinate axes and then try to rotate
it about one of the axes so we have
three different possibilities of course
we XY or z axes and so now what i think
about the z axis actually corresponds to
when we were just doing things for flat
objects in the XY plane that correspond
it rotating about the origin so secretly
we were saying we are rotating about a
point but actually it was just rotating
about the z axis just i don't want to
you know introduce the z coordinate that
we did not actually need at the time so
okay so moment of inertia about the z
axis so what's the distance to the z
axis well we've said that's exactly our
that's the cylindrical coordinate R so
the square of a distance is just R
squared now if you didn't want to do it
in central coordinates then of course R
squared is just x squared plus y squared
square of distance from the z axis is
just x squared plus y squared similarly
now if you want the distance from the x
axis well that will be Y squared plus Z
squared it right convince yourselves on
the picture or else just argue by
symmetry you know if you change the
positions of the axes so moment of
inertia about the x axis is double
integral of Y squared plus Z squared
Delta DV and moment of inertia about the
y axis is the same thing but now with x
squared plus Z squared and so now if you
try to apply these things for flat
solids that are in the XY plane so where
there's no Z to look at well you see
these formulas become the old formulas
that we had but now you know they all
fit together in a more symmetric way
any questions about that nope okay so
these are just formulas to remember so
let's do okay so let's do an example was
that a question that I missed no okay
so let's find the moment of inertia
about the z axis of a solid cone between
Z equals a times R and Z equals B so
just to convince you that it's a cone so
Z equals a times R means you know the
height is proportional to the distance
from the z axis so let's look at what we
get if we just do it in the plane of a
blackboard so if I go to the right here
R is just the distance from the z axis
the height should be proportional with
probability factor a so that means you
know I take a line with slope a same on
the left
well it's the same story except distance
to the z axis is still positive so I get
the symmetric thing and in fact it
doesn't matter which vertical plane I do
it in this is the same you know if I
rotate about the z axis see there's no
theta in here so it's the same in all
directions so I claim it's a cone where
the slope of the Rays is a and Z equals
B well that just means we stop in a
horizontal plane at height me okay so
let's solid cone where it just looks
like this that's all solid okay so it
has a flat top let circular top and then
it's pointing and the point is that V
the tip of it is at the origin
so let's try to compute its moment of
inertia about the z axis so that means
you know maybe this is like a tub that
you're going to spin and it tells you
how hard it is to actually spin that tub
actually that's you know also useful if
you're going to do mechanical
engineering because you know if you're
trying to design gears and things like
that it will rotate you might want to
know exactly how much effort you'll have
to put to actually get them to spin and
you know whether you actually going to
have a strong enough engine or whatever
to do it okay so what's the amount of
inertia of this guy well that's the
triple integral of well we have to
choose X square plus y squared or R
squared let's see I think I want to use
cylindrical coordinates to do that given
the shape so we use R squared I might
have a density that let's say the
density is one so I don't have density
I still have DV now it will be my choice
to choose you know between doing the DZ
first or doing the rdrd theta first just
to show you how it goes the other way
around let me do it rdrd theta DZ this
time you know then you can decide on the
case by case basis which one you like
best
okay so if we do it in this direction it
means that in the inner and middle
integrals we've fixed a value of Z and
for that particular value of Z will be
actually slicing our solid by a
horizontal plane and looking at what we
get okay so what does that look like
well I fix a value of Z and I slice my
thread by a horizontal plane well I'm
going to get a circle certainly what's
the radius well a disk actually what's
the radius of that disk yeah the radius
of the disk should be Z over a because
the equation of that cone we say that Z
equals a R if you flip it around so
let's switch to
and if a blackboard
so the equation of the cone it's Z
equals AR or equivalently R equals Z
over a so for a given value of Z I will
get okay will be disc of radius Z over a
okay so moment of inertia is going to be
when I said R squared D are D theta DZ
now so to set up V in our and middle
integrals I just set up a double
integral over this disc of radius Z over
a so that's easy R goes from 0 to 0 over
a theta goes from 0 to 2 pi and then
well if I'd set up the bounds for Z now
it's my outer variable so the question I
have to ask is what is the first slice
where is the last slice so the bottom
most value of Z would be 0 and the
topmost would be B and so that's what I
get
ok so exercise it's not very hard try to
set it up the other way around you know
with DZ first and then Rd Rd theta
it's pretty much the same level of
difficulty I'm sure you can do both of
them so and also if you want to practice
calculations you should end up getting
PI B to the 5 over 10 a to the 4 if I
got it right
okay let me finish with one more example
and try to give you plenty of practice
because in case you haven't noticed
Monday is a holiday so you don't have a
recitation on Monday which is good but
it means that there will be lots of
stuff to cover on Wednesday so
thank you okay so for example let's say
that I want to just set up a triple
integral for the region where Z is
bigger than 1 minus y inside the unit
ball centered at the origin so so the
unit ball is just you know well the
inside of the unit sphere so it's
equation if you want would be x squared
plus y squared plus Z squared less than
one ok so that's one thing you should
remember the equation of a sphere
centered at the origin is X square plus
y square plus Z square equals radius
squared and now we are going to take
this plane Z equals 1 minus y so if you
think about it it's parallel to the x
axis because there's no X in its
coordinate in its equation at the origin
the height is 1 so it starts right here
at 1 and it slopes down with Y with
slope 1 okay so it's a plane that comes
straight out here and it intersects the
sphere so here and here but also at
other point in between - any idea what
kind of shape this is well it's an
ellipse but it's even modern but it's
also a circle if you slice a sphere by
your plane you always get a circle
but of course it's a slanted circle so
if you look at it in the XY plane if you
project it to the XY plane then you'll
get an ellipse ok so we want to look at
this guy in here so how do we do that
well so maybe I should actually draw
quickly picture so in the Y Z plane it
looks just like this ok but if I look at
it from above in the XY plane then its
shadow well see it will sit entirely
where Y is positive so it
entirely above here and it goes for here
and here and in fact when you project
that slanted circle now you will get an
ellipse and well I don't really know how
to draw it well but it should be
something like this okay so now if you
want to try to set up that double
integral let's say the triple integral
well so let's say we do it in
rectangular coordinates because we are
ready evil well so then the bottom
surface okay so we do it with Z first so
the bottom surface is the slanted plane
so the bottom value would be z1 minus y
the top value is on the sphere so the
sphere corresponds to Z equals square
root of 1 minus x squared minus y
squared so you go from the plane to the
sphere and then find the bounds for x
and y you have to figure out what
exactly what the heck is this region
here ok so what is this region well we
have to figure out for what values of x
and y the plane is below the ellipse so
the condition is that sorry the plane is
bit of a sphere okay
so that's when the plane is below the
sphere that means 1 minus y is less than
square root of 1 minus x squared minus y
squared so you have to somehow
manipulate this to extract something
simpler well probably the only way to do
it is to square both sides 1 minus y
squared should be less than 1 minus x
squared minus y squared and if you work
hard enough you'll find quite an ugly
equation but you can figure out what are
then the bounds for X given Y and then
set up the integral so just to give you
a hint the bounds on Y will be 0 to 1
the bounds on X well I'm not sure you
want to see them but in case you do
it will be from negative square root of
2y minus 2y squared to square root of 2y
minus 2y squared so exercise figure out
how I got these by starting from that
now of course if we just wanted the
volume of this guy we wouldn't do it
this way we do symmetry energy with a
voltage for things so that you know our
spherical cap was actually centered in
the z axis because that would be a much
easier way to set it up but depending on
what function were integrating we can't
always do it